[Music]
in greek mythology we see
warriors everywhere whether it's a god
demigod hero or even just a well-trained
immortal
there is no shortage of conflict and war
so it's not really a surprise that there
are so many tales of brave warriors
outside of athena and a few other
examples these figures are
almost exclusively male there was a
tribe however that consisted of nothing
but
female warriors who were given their own
island out of fear
with this tribe we certainly have a
unique
and interesting story and that is why
today we are looking at the
amazons greek mythology's most feared
female warriors
so
oh
[Music]
so who were these mysterious women where
did they come from
and where in greek mythology did they
appear
the majority of greek scholars seem to
agree that this tribe
descended from the god aries and a nymph
named harmonia one of the most famous
pieces of work
detailing this would be the argonautica
the story of jason
and the argonauts as told by a polyneus
he portrays them as brutal and
aggressive
their only concern is war as that is
what they were bred for
it's not often we see women in greek
mythology portrayed in this way
even if we take the most famous example
of athena
although she is a goddess associated
with war and took
part in many battles that is only one
side of her
she's also creative strategic and
calculated she's not particularly
aggressive
or brutal so if athena represented
strategic
warfare then ares is the other side of
the coin
he represents the more physical
aggressive and gritty part of war
much of the time he's driven by blood
thirst and
raw emotion everything athena is
not when you take the nature and
temperament of their father
into consideration the way these women
are portrayed is no longer a surprise
it's what you would expect
the home of the amazons is something
that differs drastically depending on
your source
if we go with the argonautica jason and
the argonauts came across a port
that belonged to the amazons just off
the river thermadon
which would place them around modern-day
turkey
here they had a capital city known as
the miscrea
which heracles visited during his 12
labors
some believe they instead migrated from
libya
and others placed them much further
north around ukraine
and russia regardless of the location
it's always
isolated and just outside of what the
ancient greeks considered
the civilized world which fits their
wild and unpredictable nature
men were not allowed to live on this
island and for the most part
they lived completely isolated from the
male populace
except when it came to reproduction and
war
when it came to keeping the tribe
populated once a year they would visit a
nearby
all-male warrior tribe known as the
gargarians
when the children were born if they were
male then they would be sent to the
gargarians
if they were female then they would be
raised by the amazons
in the miscrea there is also a story
that states the two tribes once lived in
the miscrea together
but after war broke out they agreed to
go their separate ways
only concerning each other with matters
of reproduction
in the same way we've grown accustomed
to the spartan way of life
being that of a warrior the amazons
raised their children in the same vein
this upbringing would not have been for
the weak hearted
they were so committed to this way of
life that they would even go as far as
searing the breasts of newborn children
giving them a wider range of motion
making using a bow and throwing a
javelin
much easier over the years the amazons
had
many different queens one of the main
issues of going to war so often
is that the chances of your leader being
killed in battle
are greatly increased and so there would
always have to be someone ready to step
up and assume the mantle of queen
as we've already mentioned the
argonautica and the labors of heracles
maybe we should start with those stories
first
jason and the argonauts didn't really
have much interaction with the amazons
themselves
as they journeyed through the black sea
in their quest to find the golden fleece
they stopped off at a port to rest when
they found out that they had docked in
amazon territory they quickly fled and
set sail
luckily for them this went unnoticed as
the amazons were still
dealing with the aftermath of heracles
visiting their city
for his ninth labor heracles was told to
travel to the miscrea and retrieve a
magical girdle
given to the then amazon queen hippolyta
by her father aerys a task that would
not be
easy to fulfill without bloodshed this
was then made even harder when the
goddess hera disguised herself
as one of the amazons and started
spreading rumors that heracles was there
to kidnap their queen
when heracles and his men arrived on
their shores they were attacked
immediately
and so with the option of diplomacy no
longer available heracles killed
hippolyta
took the belt and sailed away leaving
the amazons to find
a new leader in an alternative version
to this story heracles and hippolyta
came to a peaceful agreement
regarding the girdle you'd imagine
heracles being a big
strong warrior would have meant there
was some kind of mutual respect between
the two
unhappy with how successful these
negotiations were the goddess hera would
once again
intervene spreading rumors that these
guests were here to kidnap hippolyta
and the rest of this story plays out the
same way as the first
there is much more to hippolyta though
than just this story
some say that when the hero theseus
visited her kingdom
she fell in love and agreed to leave her
people behind
travelled to athens got married and bore
his child
making her the first and only amazon to
wed
this angered the rest of the amazons
enough for them to declare
war on athens in what is referred to as
the attic
war in other renditions theseus changed
his mind and chose to marry the cretian
princess
phaedra hippolyta incense then rallied
the amazons and attacked
athens during their wedding ceremony in
this battle hippolyta once again
dies either at the hands of theseus
achilles or
accidentally by her own sister in all
honesty it's a bit confusing because she
appears in so many different stories and
she's always a slightly different person
some even started to assume that this
must have been referring to more than
just
one woman so you may as well just pick
the story you like
best they are also mentioned in regards
to the trojan war
where they swap sides halfway through
showing they don't really care for
allegiances
or politics if there was a war nearby
they would participate with very few
questions asked
towards the end of the trojan war the
amazons were under the rule of
hippolytus sister queen
panther celia who decided to switch
sides and fight
against the greeks which would end
rather poorly
her encounter with achilles is detailed
in ethiopis
one of the lost epic cycles that made up
the trojan cycle
the queen arrived on the battlefield
with 12 other amazons and after a day
she confronted achilles and just like
many before who thought they could best
achilles
she died in combat but after removing
her helmet
achilles saw a woman that he fell in
love with
one of his fellow soldiers known as
thirsities made sure to show his
disapproval of achilles falling in love
during combat
even questioning whether his ability to
lead had been compromised
in some accounts he even went as far as
to tear out the eyes of pentacelia to
make the point
and that he certainly did achilles
turned his love and sorrow into anger
and killed the soldier where he stood
this led to him then having to journey
to the island of lesbos to be cleansed
of this murder
before rejoining the battle it does
almost seem to be a mandatory
requirement
that at some point in a greek hero's
life they will encounter the amazons
one of the stories we haven't mentioned
is in the redemption arc of
bellerophon here the amazon tribe is
located near lycia
and bellerophon is sent to quell the
uprising by the king of leicester
in the hopes that he will be killed
during this task
with the help of pegasus he's able to
defeat the amazons
and the nearby solemoi tribe by flying
above
and dropping boulders on them there are
also
numerous stories involving dionysus
one were a conflict between him and the
amazons results in a full-blown war
where he chases them from island to
island killing most of them
on what would later be dubbed the
blood-soaked field
they were also mentioned during his
conquest of india
being listed amongst those who fought
alongside dionysus
against some of the titans homer's iliad
mentions the tomb of myrene
an amazon queen who in later
interpretations was said to have
conquered parts of libya when she
invaded
atlantean cities the most famous of
these being the city of cerney which the
amazons sacked
all of the men were then murdered and
the women and children were
forced into slavery myrin however showed
considerably more compassion towards the
people than the rest of the amazons
and agreed to look upon the city with
kindness
those who wish to settle and live in
peace with the natives did so and those
who were more bloodthirsty took their
talents
elsewhere the poet theodorus believed
myrene
and the rest of the amazons charged into
battle accompanied by gigantic snakes
and even went as far to describe a
battle between the amazons
and the gorgons from which the amazons
emerge victorious
it's also quite common to see these
women riding horses into battle
and this is reinforced by the notion
that the amazons were amongst the first
to ride
cavalry into battle the author palifatus
wrote a text trying to rationalize many
aspects of greek mythology
he believed the amazons may not have
even been women
they instead could have been men
mistaken for women because of their
clothing
their hair tied back in headbands and
their shaven facial hair
it's a theory that makes sense if these
tribes ever existed
but from a mythological storytelling
standpoint it's not one that many poets
agree on
a much more common explanation is that
the amazon legend may have been inspired
by the real-life
warrior women of the surrounding nations
such as the sarmatians and scythians
despite which explanation you prefer
there are many named amazons in greek
and roman mythology some of these may be
no more than a name on a piece of paper
and others having elaborate stories of
their conquests and battles
i can't really make a video about the
amazons and not mention the massive
influence they had on dc
comics especially with wonder woman over
the years the origin story of wonder
woman
has been retconned and rewritten a few
times
but the influence greek mythology had on
these comics is plain to see
the amazons live on paradise island
which is also known
as the miscrea an island isolated from
the rest of the world
hippolyta is the queen of the amazons
and panthecilia is also a name that
appears in the comics
and the movie the amazons in these
comics are super fast
strong durable and can use all manner of
weapons
they also never age as long as they
remain in thamiscria
war is something that we see all the
time in greek mythology
and it's often men leading these battles
so it's interesting to have an
all-female tribe that also conquered
parts of the world
and took part in every war they could
even if they were just men mistaken for
women
or women mistaken for men if there's one
thing we've learned
it's that wherever the amazons went
there was bloodshed
and death but let me know what you think
i'm sure some of you have come across
references in tv shows and books that
you'd like to share
as always i've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
reminding you that all these episodes
are now available in podcast form
so why not listen to those too
you